come take a walk with me
around Longyearbyen that's the largest
town on the Norwegian islands of
Svalbard
parts of it may look familiar
but make no mistake this place is
different
at 78 degrees north it is just 800 miles
or 1300 kilometers from the North Pole
and with over 2,000 permanent residents
it is the northernmost real town on
earth
there are only 50 kilometres of road
including the small streets between
houses so people get around the island
mainly on snowmobile
in fact there are more registered
snowmobiles than residents
anyone leaving town is required to
travel with a gun and someone who knows
how to use it
because the islands are also home to
polar bears
the average daytime high is below
freezing for all but four months of the
year
and from the end of October to
mid-february
the Sun doesn't rise at all
this is the long polar night
living here is tough
this past December an avalanche in town
destroyed ten homes which used to be
here killing two people
so how did this cold remote ice-covered
archipelago come to be inhabited
well the hills around town are rich in
coal deposits that have been mined for
over a hundred years
the coal was transported to the port via
a series of aerial tramways some of
which remain today though they are no
longer operational
coal is a reminder that Svalbard was not
always an Arctic ice world 360 million
years ago it was actually in the tropics
just north of the Equator a swampy area
it was covered with the precursors to
modern ferns which were much larger than
they are today reaching ten to thirty
meters in height this vegetation was
then covered in mud and sand and
submerged under the sea over time it
turned into the cold deposits that in
the twentieth century brought miners
from Norway Russia and the US
most of the coal mines have now closed
and the economy is gradually shifting
towards tourism education and research
tourists take trips on snowmobiles and
dog sleds there is a University Center
in Svalbard which offers semester
courses in biology physics and geology
and up on the side of a mountain is the
Svalbard global Seed Vault
but that's a story for another time
the locals tell me that interest in the
region from different nations is
increasing as the globe warms and Arctic
ice shrinks trade routes are opening up
across the north
and small bard is strategically placed
between North America Asia and Europe so
one day in the futures fall bard may no
longer be as cold or as remote as it
once was
but for now it is a reminder of how
through our ingenuity people can live in
even the most inhospitable of places
you